seven astronauts aboard the  international space station on high  alert because of more than fifteen  hundred pieces of new space debris the  u.s government says the space junk was  created when russia destroyed one of its  own satellites with a missile  that debris crosses paths with iss about  every 90 minutes even a small fragment  could cause devastating damage to the  station  with these 1500 pieces of track  trackable orbital debris  poses a risk not only to those  astronauts not only to those cosmonauts  but to satellites to the interests of  all nations  mission control says the iss will remain  on alert for the next few days